i think when it comes specifically a
trans youth in general everybody could
do something when it comes to that
there's a fight for everyone and right
now we are under a lot of high fire and
the only way is to speak up we need to
rally around our people we need our
allies as much as possible and also we
need to get down there and show them
that we're real human beings and that
you know
there doesn't need to be any kind of
investigation when it comes to a child
coming to their parent and letting them
know who they are yes
and i want to piggyback um off of what
mj said i think it's really important
for everyone who wants to help to become
informed to learn as much as they can
about trans experiences from trans
people and also there are a few things
that i think people making these laws
need to understand that they cannot
possibly understand because they are not
trans nor are they parents of trans kids
and so one of the things that i think
about often is this idea that the
existence and visibility of trans and
queer people is going to bring and
create and inspire more people to be
trans and queer not only is that idea
vilifying trans and queerness but it
also isn't true or accurate because a
lot of trans queer and trans and queer
people who have never met or seen or
heard of trans and queer people exist
every day and and and we we we have we
have we have been born and have come
into realization and self-actualization
with how we feel and who we are a lot a
lot of us have without having any other
contact with other queer and trans
people so it's really it's it's not only
not only are these laws are dangerous
and extremely harmful and destructive to
families but it's also misinformed
incredibly misinformed it's dangerous
and if anybody actually cares about what
is right and what is correct and what is
reasonable people really really should
think about what is actually happening
to innocent children and mothers and
fathers and doctors and medical
professionals who are really looking
sincerely to support just trans youth
and their care that they need in this
country
our kids period their kids so they need
to be able to experience a childhood we
need to be prioritizing them being able
to experience a full childhood their
kids